so guys when they come to you and they
say yes just to say yes that's it
because you hear Lego and you go yes
that sounds like a fun job
yeah they say Ninjago and you go what's
that somebody who has children they and
they look at you like they go have you
heard of Star Wars or and like something
like a Fight Club for kids
oh yeah
if they don't the only talk about it
amongst themselves yeah if you don't
have a kid you don't have a kid no clue
it exists yeah yeah yeah well when was
the last time let me before you guys got
these roles when was the last time you
actually played with like yours day yeah
there's a special lego sets it's like
adults it's like you can make they build
the White House you could build like you
know they're really pretty they have
like puzzles more than they are they go
mm-hmm and so I have a friend who would
get one for every birthday and so I have
she did a huge nerd he well his wife
would get him there and I feel like it
was a it was a big thing in their in
their life music if she goes oh yeah no
she said yes all right you know she's
not as I was going for the bad boy right
yeah exactly
it may be a bad boy of Legos I don't
know like in his lego building great
Lego motorcycle I mean that you've got
the the Coco honor you know inside where
instead of now you guys play you know
you're you're the loads parents oh yeah
boy boy girl unload it slowly I named
him Lloyd and why is the one who why is
it lo Lloyd it wasn't it wasn't it
creative it wasn't a pre-thought
creative between she's making fun of me
because I'm not a great person who reads
he's a grown-up Rob reading so when I
read this script I was like we were
recording it and
I was you know to the first session I
just went the Lloyd and I was like oh
it's too else I wasn't gonna and so it
actually it made us laugh so hard that
we ended up keeping it in we're like
let's just call them avoid the whole
time that's awesome
I directed charlie just dying well at
one moment
laris do you guys think that um you know
you could give any parenting advice if
you give any parenting advice to cocoa
know and to Garmadon what would it be
what would you say I could give them
some advice which is work it out it's
fine lavoy needs a father
and he needs a mother and he said plenty
of the mother know what it's better to
have no father than to have an evil
warlord as a father in your life fair no
I think you know you need a father no
matter what the father you need some
kind of a father figure so now that he's
back in his life I think they should
embrace that I think it smells like a
like a redemption story for for a
Garmadon because here's the thing yeah
koko is a strong single mother who's
been raising a boy that is actually a
ninja I think she's done a pretty good
job if you want your money though
Garmadon makes the sacrifice because he
realizes that that guy don't listen to
this guy you know what I go on abandoned
father got married which was they were
gonna be warlords together and then we
have a baby you can't be exist you can't
be a warrior with a baby
they don't make Baby Bjorn think they
talked about earlier and you said like
no we're gonna be warlords together and
then the minute the baby shows up you're
like bye so thanks work because it's all
about him and that's the Garmadon is
confident lean tom okay right and look
he loves it he's very bright 'full
extremely bright man well he's a unique
individual I mean there's not a lot of
guys that you meet out there with
forearms no am i right that's right he
has four arms look what you were walking
away from just like
with their cups they know no hands they
just cupholders he does pretty well I
mean look I mean look if you had four
arms to work with every single day like
what would you do which is amazing
I could I could look at my phone four
more times than I normally do probably
instagraming four times as much he be
crazy so it should be double tapping
double tapping double tapping double tap
I could be liking everything I mean it's
just a phone from the actual world I'll
be dropping for phone I can do breaking
four screens every day um I love the
mechs in this movie the mechs are
amazing they're super impressive if you
guys could have any mechs
in real life any giant robots what would
they be and what would you do with them
I kind of would have the one that he has
in the movie it's this big thing that he
it's not back here ya know I would have
that thing because it shoots sharks
which is hilarious I would have a
hoverboard that also has like had some
kind of you know like shoots fire or
shot but a hoverboard especially when
you're in LA I feel like the the future
let us down because back in the day we
were promised that there would be
hoverboards at least by now and you're
in trapping you look at all that extra
air space around us not be reporting on
the 405 but you know on the 405 you're
hovering above and by the way you go off
to the side of the four or five you know
you go a straight line right over LA you
get you know your back bro flies the
crow huggers why where you want to fly
when you have a hoverboard okay and
that's it's my own I'm digressing but I
just feel like the future let us down
well listen you I mean you got to go for
what you want life right yeah I just
feel like the insurance telling you then
I should build the hoverboard yeah I'm
on it